namaste what's up everyone we're about
to play something I think if anyone is
most excited about it's probably you rob
all a GTA 5 on pc today oh yeah why
don't we mess around with video editor
good good put the cops off off the CD
and then we'll make a little scene or
something or we actually could even just
go check out director mode which we do
that yep so I want to make a movie so
I'm record assuming oh I see the left
there and either start recording your
turn on action replay so I'm going to do
I'm going to turn it on start recording
because there's a bunch of cops we about
to come after you
again if you're ever going to record you
have to be in third person he had a few
people duh oh he was on the bed thank
you survive okay so let's do this uh
right sorry I'm not used to seeing ok
save slide whatever just happened last
30 seconds what a shot that's fine cool
with it that's ok so let's see oh um I
was going to create one here fine I to
clip a nice clip let's edit it yes now
you've seen this a little bit before
yeah and it was really easy to pick up I
only had about like an hour or two with
it and by like the end of it I was like
I had made like 23 videos ski so it's
player clip here mm-hmm
and rear ended no this is the cliff it's
like we were there that's why I told you
to hit people right didn't work out okay
you got it no problem my whip and I got
a crush so I think after reviewing this
clip I had a good part of the story was
the guy who was on the bench yeah I
agree so let's see what his view was
like what was life from the perspective
what's really interesting is I was
actually you when I was messing around
this before for the preview I forgot
like using the mouse it's so much easier
I was using the controller for some
reason I thought that was a seat for me
it was easier but like mouse you can get
really fine so let's see here and I want
to change this camera so i'm gonna i can
do free camera right oops so here are
take me through this i haven't seen any
of this before sure so again it's like
imagine there's a bubble around my
character so whether whatever is in the
bubble i can essentially go to or go to
eyes and change the camera to like their
perspective perspective or just track
whatever they're doing right okay and
just basically get crazy can you get
that girl in pink sea air right in front
and she like doesn't notice you yet but
she's going to let's see is it just
popped to them one at a time or can you
select her I'm gonna try okay these are
like dinner cinematic options free
camera look at current move with target
60 that's right edit camera okay Oh
and move I'm using a controller here
because this was easier for me to yeah
get up get up all up in his face I'll
see it I want to see his face human wow
he's like what are you looking out the
window where is he going like I love my
steering wheel mrs. right hand can you
get in the car can you like be in the
driver's seat next to him think so get
really perfect that's the perspective
that's the shot we want to it you know
if the change drunk I am you're drunk
density of that do intense all the way
crazy hammered drunk yeah look at that
oh that's what it's like when we drive
oh there she is she's five I guess all
right that's what we want oh she's so oh
did she dodged daughter you got it okay
that shot right there is no good because
I have no idea what I'm looking at I
need more action in this shot oh there's
some action I believe that's bench guy
bench guy so you can even I believe like
start off with like a preset camera and
then you can like change with that or
like kind of alter this one so i can go
upside down or something like that I
think like you could probably do a
pretty slick Michael Bay can you animate
the camera and actually have it circle
upside down right can you do that
absolutely oh oh that's pretty cool
yeah let's have the cameras like a
security camera let's have the camera do
a full circle and how long can the clips
be here like what's your max can you
make a movie that's like 20 minutes long
they're like broken up in the brother
than 30 seconds can you make a
screenshot I was pretty good all right
here well tell me what you're doing
first I'm trying trying to do I'm trying
to basically have this camera move
uh-huh and not not cut to the next
camera but follow it okay do you think
like because you just have so many
options at this stage it's just kind of
hard to figure out what you're actually
trying to accomplish yeah I'm not going
to spend much more time i'ma throw some
like effects on it so we can get an idea
of like oh how you can do all my stuff
it's like Instagram Touch of Evil
Normandy that's great it's like World
War two like kind of burned Oh could you
lower the speed I'd like to see it in a
little bit slow mo not that much that's
really slow and is that just for that
marker is that for your entire clip it's
for the marker right so if you can tell
here right I can see where it's getting
slow mo by the arrows like a glove now I
want it to be slow when he's like
flipping right here yeah like that's
when it's good this camera and then the
other marker it can actually be regular
speed cuz like nothing's happening cool
does the audio get slow mode too is like
all the girls like yeah
exactly what about the radio well I can
always go if I wanted to keep the song
the same I could go back cuz radio
separate right right so I could cut out
radio here and I could put in my song
all right that doesn't get slowed them I
have to do that later so say will call
here whatever the hell this video is
ready oh that's yeah it's a cab shot
brilliant we can change this yeah let's
do back or right yeah it's good we
haven't had a real shot in a while do a
little oh yeah handheld that sounds
great alright so i can even change the
camera a little bit more here no i will
leave it there I feel like you can spend
all goddamn day on this oh well all
right all right now let's add some music
so imma save this yeah now I'm going to
go back timeline so yeah if I again it's
30 second clips this was what we use the
action replay so it just recorded like
an event recorded what happened and that
was 30 seconds right if I were to let it
running it would just break them up into
30 second clips and I would have to pull
it from like my selection back here okay
so i would go like back here add clip
here is we're glad your radio chatter
your track so any songs you have in mind
let's get to the new radio station new
radio station so the lab
here well I don't really know our
currency and Freddie Gibbs are you
looking oh it's good oh you might not
see it because its currency with a
dollar sign for the S fette is the first
I assume it means fun Betty which is my
favorite type of cake is it must be what
this is about well so that's there we
want like mid-song right sure based on
my knowledge of the fette song so let's
trim nope god it's like looking at you
Final Cut Pro the new one I don't like
when things snap I'll tell you where I
want the clip to go yeah you don't know
me so start there 11 seconds and we can
go this is actually so true I think
let's just put it in there this happens
when you get people who edit video for a
living to edit a clip for this game it's
way too long actually cut and print am i
am going to export it because I think
that's gonna take some time here's a
preview see if this works
oh it's beautiful can you hear music
yeah it's everything I thought it would
be right here hey smash God shot slow-mo
and then world war two status and then
he just pulls away Instagram filter
great she's Ryan cool that's it it's
beautiful it's the most beautiful video
you ever made Rob and that's saying
something about favor your skill as a
video editor I've never seen anything
that nice oh thank you